Putain c'est ouf, quoi ! Qu'est-ce qu'il fout, Flavien ?
Bah là, il vient de me dire qu'il était en retard...
Qu'il était désolé.
Putain mais c'est quand même dingue, quoi !
A chaque fois qu'on fait un truc avec lui, il est toujours en retard, quoi.
T'es... T'es sûr je reste dans la voiture, là ?
Oui, Priscilla, je suis sûr que tu restes dans la voiture.
J'ai juste pas envie que quelqu'un te reconnaisse, c'est tout.
J'ai envie de pisser, là.
Yop !
Et faites pas cette gueule, je vous ai ramené du café.
Alors !
Un Ristretto...
Pour ristrett'Tony.
Frappuccino pour prisc'...
Moi, je me suis pris un petit Macchiato caramel.
Bon et toi Boris, j'ai trouvé que ça.
Tu voulais un truc salé.
T'es sérieux pour les noms, là ?
Bah quoi ?
Je sais pas, c'est quand même plus pratique pour se repérer, non ?
T'es au courant qu'on va faire un braquage ?
Bah ouais.
Et donc toi, tu donnes nos noms...
Au café...
A côté de la banque...
Ça te dérange pas, toi ?
Il est jamais content !
Bon, il est où Flavien ?
Parce que je lui ai pris un petit Latte mais c'est quand même meilleur chaud, hein ?
Bon écoutez, on va faire une pause sur Flavien, là...
Parce que ça commence à me rendre dingue, là.
Je sais même pas pourquoi on l'a pris là, cet abruti, putain.
Peut-être parce que c'est lui qui a eu l'idée ?
Oui.
Ouais, remarque t'as raison.
Message de Flavien.
Qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
J'arrive dans 2 minutes, besoin de quelque chose ?
Bah de lui, déjà.
Ce serait pas mal.
Putain, les masques...
Putain, on a oublié les masques.
Putain, j'en étais sûr on est baisé !
Pas de panique, les gars ! J'ai tout prévu !
Vous croyez quoi, hé !
Ouais, du coup j'ai pris des politiciens.
Je me suis dit que ça ferait plus original.
Toi, tiens.
'ttends, 'ttends, hé !
Il a fait de la politique Francis Lalanne ?
Non, non mais attendez, non non il a...
Bon bah je fais pas de braquage avec Francis Lalanne sur ma tête.
Ah ouais mais non je suis sûr ça t'irait vachement bien !
Putain, c'est Jean-Luc !
C'est qui, ça ?
C'est un collègue.
Vas-y, baisse-toi ! Baissez-vous, baissez-vous.
Putain, je vais me pisser dessus, là.
Vas-y, fais-le dégager.
Je crois qu'il m'a vu.
Fais-le dégager Prisc'.
Ça va ma Prisc' ?
Ça va Jean-Luc ?
Bonjour.
Hé, ça te manquait le boulot, du coup, t'es revenue ?
Ouais. Ouais. Hé, tu sais quoi ? Remarque...
J'aurais fait pareil à ta place.
C'est-à-dire ?
Non mais attends, c'est dégueulasse ce qu'ils t'ont fait, là. Ils t'ont virée après 10 ans.
Toi, tu trimes, tu trimes. En plus, avec ton mari au chômage, tes gosses et tout...
C'est dégueulasse.
En plus, je crois qu'ils prévoient d'autres licenciements dans la boîte.
Ah bon ?
Moi, je sais pas comment tu fais pour rester aussi sereine. Moi ?
Moi ?
Moi, ils m'auraient fait ça ?
Moi, je pourrais faire des...
Des trucs...
Pas cool je pense, tu vois ?
Pas cool, c'est-à-dire ?
Je... J'ai pas... J'ai pas l'idée, là, maintenant...
Tu vois, mais je pense que... Oula !
Attention, tu vois ?
Ouais.
Francis Lalanne ?
Francis Lalanne ! Ah oui, oui, oui.
C'est mon idée, c'est moi qui...
Le mal qu'on se dit.
L'amour maladie.
Les grains de frimas !
Que l'on sème.
Les portes qui claquent.
Les "j'en ai ma claque"
C'est du cinéma
Quand on s'aime
Fais-moi l'amour
Fais-moi l'amour !
Fais-moi l'amour !!
Pas la guerre !
Hé, je veux pas faire l'amour, je rigole.
Tu me regardes...
Non, c'est bon.
Ça marche.
Bon allez ma Prisc'...
Hé moi j'y vais, hein.
Réunion de 8h40 tu sais ce que c'est...
Ah oui !
Ciao.
Allez, salut !
Ouais, salut !
Ouais, maintenant qu'il nous a vu faut qu'on le tue.
T'es con, toi ou quoi ?
C'est pour ça qu'on a acheté des masques.
Ah oui, c'est vrai.
C'est moi qui les ai pris, en plus.
Bon, faut y aller là !
Parce que les convoyeurs de fond vont pas tarder à arriver donc...
De toute façon, je crois qu'on va faire comme la dernière fois pour les vacances, hein ?
Hein ?
Bah on va partir sans Flavien.
Attendez, il y a un problème là, du coup...
Qui va s'occuper des coffres ?
Bah moi.
Moi, je peux le faire.
Je parlerai pas c'est tout.
Je connais tout par coeur, je pourrai vider les coffres les yeux fermés donc...
Pour moi, ça me va, hein.
3 clics à droite.
Ça va.
Clic, clic puis 2 à gauche...
C'est bon !
C'est bon, j'ai compris.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais, là ?
Ah désolé, j'avais trop envie.
Putain, mec...
Dans le Latte ?
Ok les gars.
Mettez vos masques.
Que la fête commence.
Bonjour.
Bonjour, excusez-moi, il va falloir dégager parce qu'on va bientôt intervenir, là.
Oui, oui bah pas de souci.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe, en fait ?
Il y a un problème ?
Ouais, un taré qui a pris la banque en otage.
Putain Flavien.
C'est Flavien.
Ah mince.
Et on peut savoir qui a fait le coup ?
Oui parce que moi, je travaillais là, en fait donc...
Ouais, je sais pas. Un certain Jean-Luc.
Je crois, il vient de se faire virer, il a pété un câble.
Et vous, vous faîtes quoi, ici ?
Nous, rien. On attend notre pote là.
On part en vacances.
A la Touquet.
Et sinon vous auriez pas un petit café en plus, par hasard ?
Non, là on a tout bu.
Je dis ça pare que j'en vois un, là. C'est pour ça, je demande.
Non mais il est un peu tiède, là.
Boh, ça c'est pas grave, hein. Vous savez au point où j'en suis...
Non mais il est...
C'est de la... Du bon bon café quoi... Ouais...
Tenez.
Merci, c'est sympa.
C'est un Robusta ?
Ouais. Ouais.
Bah ça m'a fait du bien, vous voyez ?
Ça va mieux, là.
C'est des drôles de journée comme ça...
Allez, circulez !
Au revoir.
Bon bah allez-y vous, parce que de toute façon il m'écoute plus, donc...
Ouais mais enfin moi j'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie, moi...
Bah vous parlez là, et puis vous appuyez là.
Jean-Luc !
C'est Francis, Jean-Luc.
Fais-moi l'amour !
Pas la guerre...
Dites-lui "faites pas la guerre".
Sinon il va pas...
Non mais je connais ma chanson merci.
Oui bah alors, allez-y, alors.
Pas la guerre !
J'ai dit Fais-moi l'amour Jean-Luc.